welcome to this video round for coverage
of the sink filled Cup played in San
Luis USA let's see what happened in this
round form
we had a very year spectacular
tournament up tuna with Khurana winning
all his games also against cards in
round three
so let's see this round yeah Sheila Graf
playing white against Nakamura let's
start with this game efore as usual for
Maxie me play d4 successfully against
her own you know earlier but I know
Knight f3 actually I'm sorry transposed
to a d4 time for opening yeah here we
got this early Bishop c5 line the neo
Arkhangelsk sometimes called the minor
variation I don't know this is has many
names Nakamura played that before
against Apollo in in round 3 actually
just round before that and lost somewhat
I know how to call it I thought it was a
bit of an unlucky loss in a way it was
okay most of the time but then somehow
yeah got caught wrong-footed at one
point and and lost the game he maybe had
a very good position somewhere along the
way okay we have these moves which looks
perfectly and normal it's a pretty this
is a very solid approach for white he
very often goes for a quick a4 instead
trying to with this this a knight a3
pressurize and sometimes win the b5
point yeah yeah and the outs
approach is more like account develop
first and this is what we get Bishop e3
they are just setting for good
development
note that this is as usual failing to
Bishop d5 attacking two nodes yeah black
event castles 92 age six
yeah h6
designed to prevent a possible Bishop g5
but also maybe allow an IG for without
white being able to play Bishop g5 this
is also why he Wentz age three now
taking the square under control so we
have a very harmonious development on
the white side the blood cannot complain
complain as well Bishop on b7 and p6 are
actively placed and you have a very
typical maneuver to follow it we see
this immediately rook e1 and now black
is some deciding decides to to take on D
form a decision not to be taken lightly
as you give up the center for the moment
yeah and more conservative approach
maybe it's something like loopy Aid
which is not bad but nothing more as
approach a thing is is good and leads to
a very very decent play for Black Knight
a5 yeah this is the idea you want to get
this bishop strong Spanish we Bishop and
at the same time a techie form so Bishop
c2 is basically the only logical
response and now in a camera place Ruki
it yeah putting more pressure on your
form yeah how should white protect this
pawn it is it's not so easy in fact on
its same it is easy but it's it's only
with the move that it's not yeah it's
not ideal he plays a queen bee one now
to cover the the pawn you could also
advance but this is probably not not
netting very much
after c6 black is very quickly attacking
the pawn Center and has no problem to to
put his Bishop Bishop b7 into play
sometimes this d5 idea can be effective
if it blunts this Bishop here but here
c6 is coming with
yeah not queen-to-be one is probably the
better choice
yeah naka moi now played very directly
94 yeah a good move as well it makes
sure that this study off-site night is
exchanged why took and now we see the
the concrete at drd4 hangs so white has
to attend again to this poem if he goes
d5 again there is c6 not the only move
but a very logical one yeah this line
might continue with Bishop a4 trying to
use this this pin here but rook c8
really some of our problems what can do
something like this but ultimately he
will be taking here and in the position
like that should be very okay for black
he always has this counter play against
the b-pawn and white um cannot easily
organizes his pieces here against the d6
pawn it should be about equally my plate
92 and now rook b8 the good a good
strengthening move asking wide okay what
are you going to do next yeah in fact
Marshall agraphia decided to take on c4
which is a move that basically
reinforces all ambitions for an
advantage it is however very difficult
to try something else
um how are you going to improve your
position here's why you always have to
cover this before pawn if you try a move
like f3 we have the kind of trying to
cover it with the pond you run into
direct problems that factor after d5 and
it's not so easy for white to play now
if you look at if I for example which
looks very normal
the new tonight h5 gives black am yes
surprisingly good play I mean I
instantly thought that this shouldn't be
too great for white but in fact widest
in in some
substantial trouble him if he's if he's
not very cautious here something like f4
for example
looks completely normal gets answered by
c5 and this after the sequence gets
really ugly for white you can very
easily be be losing quickly something
like this will probably not end very
well my queen d4 is coming so excellent
position for black f4 it's not the best
move here but it is clearly showing that
blacks counter play is very strong and
white pieces are not very coordinated
yeah right took on e4 and after Bishop
takes Bishop takes rook takes we see
that this this trade has led to a
position where white has an isolated
pawn on d4 and possibly black has
chances to use the d5 square but white
has some very very decent active pieces
especially the knight on sea floor we
see that after those moves I think there
are never yeah yeah very logical in a
way Knight f4 did the intermediate move
was necessary this trick but it was okay
25 and now he returned he will see that
this is a very well coordinated position
black has this pressure on d4 but white
has it yeah after this reliably covered
and it's not apparent how black should
increase his play against the d4 pawn
white is just active enough it's sort of
balancing balancing out position yeah
like now when c5 trying to clarify the
situation here immediately yeah it's
important to note that this is a bad
move 93 is strong for white yeah
something like that you really don't
want your bad King
t5 coming so c5 was perfectly okay black
also could could just employ a citywide
strategy there was nothing wrong with
that if anybody black can can try
something but c5 was was okay after this
we have those traits and b3 root d6 and
TN a draw was agreed which pretty much
is the the logical result maybe of this
game it all looked very very equal ish
like didn't really have any problems out
of the opening
this maneuver here with with nights and
for seems to get give like so much
pressure against the center that he
should be it should be perfectly fine so
it looked like a correct logical in a
way draw to me okay let's look at to par
love no thousand to par love next yeah
thousand I guess badly needs a win yeah
after his loss against term corona let's
see what he's doing to try to win place
d4 and we get a new Mizzou Indian hard
to predict to Palace openings you place
all kinds of openings but okay the new
zone is of course one of them Knight f3
d6 how garden comes up with this move
Bishop d2 yeah this is the kind of setup
that you quite often see from from from
let's say yeah somewhat lower rated claw
clasp they want to avoid the double pawn
has a very ruthless reputation this move
but it's nevertheless of course playable
and and very solid white erm can
definitely expect to survive the opening
after that it sort of shows in sorry
Cotton's intention to not try to
surprise to Paulo in any way with a
sharp opening but to just play a long
game and this is what we got we should
be seven
g3 that's the setup c5 that's a very
typical reaction in this in this type of
position the idea is that c5 here as
black is pretty quickly on this long
diagonal basically forces White's to
take on c5 yeah something I mean this is
simply blundering here on d4 yeah white
might get it back with 95 but this is
not not very health very helpful so why
basically has to take and now Bishop
takes this structure is well known of
course it could easily arise from from
the head shock you know C and D pawn
exchange but compared to the head shock
here black of course is much more active
we don't have a queen in the center on
d4 and things like that so it's a very
very decent structure here in this
position black has to decide how to how
to set up his pieces there are there are
many possible setups you can just play
96 for example if you if you like what
the part of a does is also pretty
standard he just plays Bishop e7 back
it's a very well known regrouping from
other lines that have the same the same
structure what black cam is trying to do
is he's clearing this square for the
knight iam wants to get the knight to c5
possibly to e4 Knight M the Bishop on c5
is not doing that much and this also
allows under it depends on the
circumstances of course to set up to set
up ahead shock if you like the typical
six rank poor information council plays
Bishop to f4 yeah this makes sense now
especially as the bishop is not on
before anymore you cannot get it out of
form so Bishop f4 986 yeah it's
important to recognize he played 95 but
it's important to recognize that the
move Bishop d6 here it's not
too much white can't play that but it's
not really any effective yeah black can
do something like this just just Knight
and c5 say rook c1 and then 94 this is a
very typical way to play putting the
night there and it makes sure that you
get this piece traded and with more
exchanges blacks position becomes easier
and easier to play it can make me play
rook the eight d5 or just rook c8 it's a
very very resilient structure ok night
b5 this is a bit more interesting trying
to put something on d6 and then keep it
down
so d5 was played just preventing Bishop
d6 on 96 96 probably be more dangerous
yeah and carson wentz 95 this is the
only chance to get something yeah using
this diagonal 95 and also covering b7
and rook c1 getting this piece into play
yeah now we see an interesting a
sequence of moves after a six carson
just dropped back to c3 and temporarily
gave up on d takes it takes on b7 97 and
I take Queen takes d8 note that if he
just takes here on c4 black can just
play b5 and this perfectly okay
I mean White has no yeah no big idea
here can go 95 intending 96 but after
Lucas e8 this is just securely covered
and here white has absolutely nothing
and it's not just nothing it's it's
really very very little to to hope for
yeah I mean sometimes you have positions
where you don't have any advantage but
you have some ideas but here this is
just absolutely nothing
this is probably why Carlin chose to
trade one point is that now Luke d8 was
played ninety eight after night c4 is
good for wide yeah yep something like
that yeah it's not very advisable but
this is perfectly okay book takes yeah
and now we went to c6 again avoiding
this this capture as something like this
is leading nowhere rooks the a-league
and if you want also Bishop d6 but rook
c8 is easier just covering here in in
this position there's simply nothing to
do yeah he went to c6 and this way
I think keeping at least some some
initiative in a way rookie HM no other
choice and true q1 of course this is
always here this is covered at the
moment very important and so rookie one
this is taking the the D file and yeah
here it's a it's a matter of precise
defense by black you place h6 which is a
good move it's important to note that b5
this is very normal looking it's not
very good due to a form after if for
black has a very hard time to keep his
Queen side porn together this is this is
for instance just giving up this porn
not good and also with problems if you
lose the pawn back without any
particular yeah action against the c6
Knight then this is just not good yeah
something let's say like this this is
very annoying from like Ana this Knight
is a very strong piece and those pawns a
week you only should return the pawn if
you really gain something in the process
we will see it in the game h6 was played
so a good waiting move no before taking
the
to control under control and now Bishop
c5 was played here activating this and
possibly allowing moves like this yeah
cause no I decided to force Metis with
e5 probably he he should I mean it was
it was hard to see some something else
ready what what else should white play
so he went see 25 this also gets the
pawn back basically 95 now um black
definitely shouldn't try to keep his
material in some way this for example
after 94 it's just leading to trouble
this is protected that's h3 coming
against Knight has no square and a move
like night h7 you really don't even
consider this is just too bad your
knight inform this is hanging route 37
yeah you absolutely must give back the
pawn ok 95 takes takes takes and now b5
and here this is a case where black has
returned the pawn as I mentioned earlier
but you should have some sort of
compensation for this for this return of
the pawn and here it is the fact that
the knight on c6 cannot be maintained
with Ruby 6 or sometimes rook c8 this
night is going to be expelled from c6
yeah here Cardin played the move Bishop
e3 just getting rid of this this Bishop
it looks very ugly due to due to the
double pawns but it it seems that it's
difficult really to suggest to suggest
something else that at least keep some
salt play in the position note that this
rook is 6 move was really something
serious if if white plays B 3 for
example which looks normal
the neutral I can say rook c8 ROP 6 is
really is really coming
I mean look like something like this for
example check
and and black is starting to to press on
the queenside he's got a poor majority
him and those pieces are not helping
very much it's just one one possible
line also that's also um Ruki six here
something like that for example is also
not very promising for white to say the
least yeah this is probably the best
move just getting rid of this rid of
this bishop and white can still hope to
to get something simply because of his
more active pieces the knight on c6 and
the rook here a fianchetto of knight is
very rarely a good piece but it seems
that it's still all in the balance
Ruki six needs to go back and be three
that's the point white wants to open up
the Queen side get in with his rooks
yeah but Topalov is playing a good
defense here rook c8 covering this rook
c5 that's a good move getting rid of
this active rook and the palm that you
that your news here is of no importance
as black gets lots of activity in return
the night is on d3 and there is also
rugby too in the mix of course if I've
also hangs yeah white now I cannot
really keep you v if he wants to cover
this that's just this move jack
absolutely pointless yeah this is why
you went with this but after this
capture here the position is just equal
it's not much really not much happening
the game in fact continued for a while
and still had one interesting point they
don't want to get into detail with this
portion of the game Carson is really
trying to press some water out of stone
yeah but as it happens if you handle a
stone with your hand you might hurt
yourself
and it was it got very very close to
white being in trouble we will see that
later yeah go up - yes 45 I just want to
go there maybe this with that little
things along the way but here in this in
this position
it was interesting here it was a black
smooth and we see that whites maneuvers
have led to a situation where the knight
on b8 is somewhat stranded to paddle off
now took on a5 after which group chicken
and rook takes a6 led to this night end
game which is a total wrong so could you
have played better yeah he could have
but it probably would have ended in a
draw anyway
still he should have found tested cards
in him much more Luke c5 was a move that
is very interesting and this was also
suggested after the game cards inaudible
of that year could have played that into
Paulo reacted yeah very very surprised
that he had not seen it on this
evaluated it I don't know there was a
funny picture there on on Twitter okay
rook c5 yeah what's the idea yeah that
idea's what should should why dunno if
you move the rook somehow let's say here
yeah just taking this and no problem
once I have a black is just the a pawn
up and we'll play here and push the pawn
so white must exchange there is nothing
else and after Knight takes you
immediately see wow this Knight is
trapped the funnier thing is however it
seems that white is just about owning a
draw but it's it's very close call yeah
what in fact you can can give this up
and now go for counter play with his
King and it seems really to be it seems
to be it wrong it's quite quite funny
for example if he if we continue this
line the King c6 kf4 King D 5 and then
let me
my nose mmm there is this candy five
I think it's g5 right yeah you go g5y a
g5 intending to take on age six and play
King f5 and there is simply no win it's
quite quite amazing something like this
might happen
take take King f5 yeah and the bodice is
black smooth now so if you play
something like this there is there is
absolutely no progress to be made
you can if you had totally office black
you might even lose but this is of
course this is of course a draw it is
quite interesting that this is it wrong
I didn't really find any wind and the
engine is also just on zero zero zero if
you give it a bit of time it's really
impossible a piece down but white is
just quick enough to to enter them black
can also try to to give up the e pawn
directly if you I mean I mean something
like this is also also possible to try
but it also seems to me to draw quite
quite amazingly now something like this
the night and it's well known that the
night is notoriously bad against against
a pawn here on the on the edge of the
bone and this is one of those cases it
just seems to be wrong the funny but
certainly what the power of could have
tried to exceed five in addition there
is 795 which they have someone on the
same idea
it wants to camera a six and make sure
that this night is not not coming out
whiter ever can play route g8 back and I
don't really see if black can win here
it looks good for black but how can you
actually win um I have looked at it a
bit with with the engine but it
only gives lines that don't really make
lots of sense to me like this for
example might be three look be three and
can something something like this is by
the engine but this that's really not
made much sense we just just just a
shuffle probably really dearest it is
really just drawn from me but the power
of could have tried with this I mean
what she did was not putting white into
him to any danger by the way one
interesting point is that here when
cousin played King f2 King Eaton was
better this is also the move that really
got him into the stroller after king f26
it is important to note that now Knight
takes a six is not good look a five not
b4 b5 and in this position you cannot
retreat due to rook b2 and black wins
the piece if the King would have gone to
eat you
there would be King D - now which is not
possibly this is why King e - was was
better not easy to see of course yeah in
the game Jack we got to this match night
and game where they continued the bitter
but there was sadly nothing happening in
fact continued to to this position where
there were no pawns left on the board so
it is really the draw of war draws yeah
I guess pretty correct result maybe the
power could have could have gotten
somewhere on 45 at least putting some
pressure on white but yeah I guess I'm a
pretty pretty correct wrong so let's
look at Kara wanna aronia next this is
the the Battle of them the yeah the two
players competing for the the number
number two spot and the rostra wanna
with his free wins has overtaken Aronian
mmm here this also may be a chance for
Oneonta to get closer to Khurana in the
standings with three out of three he's
hard to catch anyway yeah he for the
normal new form
Fabiano and we have the room as we have
so often Bishop e7 yeah Aronian is very
often trying to reach the Marshall
attack his main weapon against e4 but
nowadays the Martian is not allowed so
often karana isn't like one of the
players who sometimes allows the
Marshall and also has gotten in wins
there I think also against Aronian but
he goes for d3 one of those yeah d3
lines that are always available to white
try to to do yeah sort of playing very
very subtle maneuvers those those little
things that might lead to small edges if
played correctly this is this game is in
fact a little bit of a mystery to me but
let's see what what happened a
three-year normal you want to avoid
Knight a5 getting your Bishop exchanged
here it goes
and aronia plays Bishop e6 um yeah this
kind of structure is well known the
precise position maybe not that much but
it's nothing spectacular black ones to
get rid of them
Bishop his some let's say the price he
pays for getting rid of the bishop is
this construction damage before they are
a good move now if black he gets in c5
even and then knight c6 he has no
problems at all so you better push the
knight back before c5 is possible Bishop
d2 yeah and now we come to a position
where I mean I play d4 you find this
black and I could easily have this
position as black and I always think
okay what are you going to do to me here
how am I ever going to lose this is
black what's your idea anyway I always
have a hard time to really under
10th when white is doing here but this
probably only shows my limited
understanding um yeah I think like it's
just okay I mean there shouldn't be
anything bad happening to him
he played d5 probably not a move that I
personally would play I'm making this
comparison here but I would play because
I could easily have the position so I
probably want to go to keep the
structure as it is for a while but it's
not a bad move of course you know
getting a little bit of activity in the
center it it weakens a bit d5 but
shouldn't be a problem
in fact you know p.m. all this is
probably about equal now Carolina finds
a nice damp like night - a - I think
this is this is not a new idea but very
nice one nevertheless he recognizes
correctly of course that the knight on
c3 is not a great piece and he intends
to play this maneuver night going to be
three from them controlling c5 maybe
jumping to c5 in the right circumstances
also preventing a six a five so the
knight on v3 is quite a good piece
interesting maneuver 97 Queen e2 and
deform yeah black decides to close the
center yeah
very young very is a committal decision
of course you cannot take it back but I
don't see no I don't see a reason to
criticize this I think like some what
like did wrong because he got in trouble
later it's only coming this this all
looks very normally a White has
completed his maneuver here to b3 the
knight on e4 is looking at c3 so that
this this pawn break where the C pawn is
not so easily playable and from a for
the night also supports later c5 so a
good good
the interesting movement is coming later
ruk f7 now rooks c1 back maybe maybe c3
sometimes now route d8 was played which
looks at the d3 pawn to make it harder
to play c3 and Here Come on a plate
Knight to g5 and now we come to a very
interesting situation because aronia now
plays the move rook f6 he just moves the
rook and this is a case where probably
we are talking about the case where my
positional understanding is simply not
enough to me I mean if I had this
position as black I would probably think
about 30 seconds and then just take this
night off simply based on the fact that
this is potentially a bad Bishop and why
not why not exchange it for a night I
mean this looks very normal but I really
don't see why he had something like this
let's say rook f8 and yeah I'm sure f3
f1 something like that I don't know I
don't know really
and then maybe that's a night to be 8
and 10 degree 97 possibly sad c5 isn't
black just okay here what is what is why
it's a grand plan him still c3 or c4 at
some point a few black is just okay and
I don't really see any big big idea here
for what
why shouldn't you take on on g5 and give
up your take and take with your your bad
Bishop I really don't know I really
don't know you know the computer gives
white something like 0.1 or 0.2 which
okay it's not really relevant I really
thought that black is totally okay he
didn't play that he didn't play that
probably yeah I underestimate why it's
White's chances here I'm not saying like
it's better but but I think okay well
what
the big deal am i not okay yeah yeah
okay
he played rook f6 it's not a fatal
mistake or anything just but now white
after Korea's fire is in a way getting
somewhere
yeah h7 hangs you don't really want this
jack
this looks a bit awkward for black so h6
was played the night drove back to f3
yeah here here white now has some ideas
one ideas h3 night h2 Knight g4
attacking in this rook and yes sometimes
maybe even near pawn pawn moves h4 h5 or
g4 g 5o kg 45 is very tough to play but
yeah this this pawn if sticks gives
light additional ideas and the bishop on
e7 is simply not a great piece so I
would have just taken it off rook F 1
rook 8 to f7 yeah this is not a mistake
probably but it somehow goes into the
wrong direction it seems this seems
seems a bit better look at this here
after Age 3 there is this idea suddenly
Knight coming to g4 when the rook is
trapped
yeah losing in exchange and how black is
is forced to play some really ugly moves
that he didn't want to play in the first
place this is one of them g6 yeah maybe
instead of Bishop f8 e should have gone
all the way back here yeah okay
we came to this situation g6 Queen h4
Queenie 723 and now we have double
pressure on e5 and e6 Bishop g7 yeah in
this position 90 xe5 it's not that great
because
oops not there Hey he of course black
can take on f2 using this situation so
Knight a5 very interesting way to play
corona is putting this knight on the
edge of the board forces the capture and
now takes on e5 very nice he's giving up
a whole piece but he has a very nice
play for that the night must play to b7
there's no other square and as often
mentioned a fugitive might not good
the knight is not well placed and he
gets a second pawn on d6 Queen to the to
d8 + e5 this was the idea with E 5 and
f1 he gains huge space on the Kings side
he has two pawns for his piece and note
that both Knights have bad positions
they are not helping in the defense
White has ideas like Knight age 4 or
maybe move the Queen and play even g4
trapping the whole rook yeah this
position is is simply better for white
and very very tough to play um Aronian
played c5 now after some thought maybe
Knight c3 was tougher but I don't think
that this is a position that has big
chances to be defended with little time
right age for age 5 and 9 f3 this is a
stronger intending Queen g6 and g4 King
edge 7 ah this was necessary
and now Queen g4 the rookie is singing
yeah I have to put it back and now 9h
final the rook has no square to go to
yeah white will get this rook for
tonight and he will maintain those small
pawns King h8 takes takes and Queen g6
now simply g4 is the threat yeah it is
some easy to play now white just pushes
and note that you also have much more
time on the clock Queenie Adi now the
easiest way is to simply trade
takes f6 with tempo f7 with tempo and
this now getting in Bishop takes h6 if
the bishop f8 is going then there is
simply the F pawn promoting Aronian
played on for a couple of moves Knight
b6 takes 97 yeah this is rook F 1 quite
quite nice but to it easy to see after
this Bishop takes rook takes White has a
totally winning endgame yeah this wasn't
late we should age 6
Jack yeah and now multiple ways but just
keeping all this is easiest with rook g5
in mind yeah it's yeah Aronian resides
the game so this means karana is on
falling at the for our four in the
rating Y strongest tournament of all
time which is yeah Stella
result really and absolutely yeah
unexpected I mean it was pretty much you
clear to me that he was contending to
win this thing but four out of four him
it's quite a statement so fantastic
fantastic start for him would be very
difficult to to spoil this this is a
this anymore so we have him leading with
four of four then we've got my maxi
Russia der graaf mvl with 50% on won
second place two points behind and the
rest of the players are all are minus
one so quite quite funny yeah quite
funny standing yeah okay I hope you
enjoyed the coverage here thanks for
watching and I'll be back tomorrow with
round five
bye